[Music]
in Gotham news I love that guy did God
mm this one's submitted by lemon pepper
wings oh definitely stop wing stop
always that by like the parmesan wantin
it just says a jewelry stealing prank
video has gone viral ad the whole timers
a different ladies there's different
ladies yeah okay I'm not even gonna play
the music
it's so awesome I love it I want to see
how beautiful I am there she's looking
in the mirror and the other one gets
embarrassed like like she's running away
oh I like the reaction of the tell the
the clerks I like how they kind of run
fast enough really yeah because they
trying one of the smoother ones for sure
[Laughter]
oh yeah they all try to play it off what
they're laughing - they're laughing -
the cracking the [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
dying when they know it's a prank
I like pranks like this yeah it's hurt
somebody in my store I would die
laughing
that's so true what do you mean how's
that rude it's so fun I think I think
it's only funny than me because they're
all so laughing - so the joke as well so
they think it's funny so that's why it's
funny to me yeah yeah
what if they mess with that one fast
dude we're like or you even reach the
mirror that already like three punches
in you're on the ground like no where
you just this all so this has been
shared on doing in aka tik-tok yeah you
said it right so yeah and it's all
stemmed from this other viral video my
brain is working so slow right now
tell me something I don't know it's
lower than usual today okay good never
slow dude come on now anyway the point
is the original video here was from this
Indian Malaysian youtuber where he's
trying on some sneakers
oh I saw this I saw this one - oh I
thought he copied the ladies
chuckles breafast
[Laughter]
he's really oh man that was yeah guys is
laughing man I was speeding no yeah I'd
be concerned for all the copycat like
it's like it could be the next life you
know the Harlem shake challenge the only
reason why I don't like that is because
if I was the worker I would be fired
after because they would see this the
guy would rather go by John exactly but
what happened did yeah I'm like
wonder-percent
what are you gonna do after you chase
them say hey please stop exactly it's
not my story the back when I worked at
retail that we were told not to go after
yeah here - they're just like it's not
worth it just don't go after them but
that's dope if I if I saw one of my
staff like running out there's someone
I'm like hell yeah your manager now I
also have to know mine I have to know my
abilities too like for sure I'm not
catching anybody dude you can never say
never did trust me I know I fractured
both my ankles guaranteed I'm hurting
something dude it's not worth it what if
there was a bystander that was like oh
no and then they like tackle cuz I've
seen videos like that where there's
jewel thieves and they're being chased
and then a guy would just come up in
[ __ ] karate kick a minute old like
that old guy with the cane he's I put
the game behind us yeah cane it was his
own leg there's a lot of videos like
that though where there's like guys
being chasing it oh yeah one Good
Samaritan like yeah I wish I was a good
Samaritan dude I'm a good watcher I
observed really well right and then what
do you do with that information
oh if the cops come up to me I don't
snitch I'm just saying I just have you
just know
so did you see what happened yes I did
well what happened I know snitch [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are you talking about guys see
[ __ ] even though I did see [ __ ]
what other variations do you guys think
people would what the [ __ ] the speaker
one is good cuz it's like various it's
specific to the product yeah
say what this the jewelry like they're
like ready to go see the jewelry I like
the jeweler web because it's like the
sweetest little ladies funny part
because you don't expect that out of
them
or they can start going to like bike
shops you're on a bike is home running
off and come right back car dealerships
I want to see I want to see like
something that would be difficult like a
team like a Best Buy I don't know what I
don't know how you do it with the TV but
you turn it on change the channels no
you right you take it and you run to
like the nearest wall you know I do some
people some people are so good at
stealing it's unreal man when I was at
Riverside there's his do you name James
the magic he didn't have to steal he was
like a klepto he's like one of those
rich kids he lived in Diamond Bar in the
country you know the country right that
[ __ ] rich ass neighborhood where like
snoop lives that's where he [ __ ]
lived this dude was so good at stealing
I didn't even know that he was stealing
like so we would go to a food for less
like in Riverside when we would go
shopping for a [ __ ] I learned that in
order for you to steal something you
just have to steal it as if it was yours
to begin with
yeah and that's what he would do he
would walk in just put stuff in the car
he would walk out like it was nothing
and I had a second guest like did he pay
for that and he never did so he was
still hungry man dinners man dinners are
delicious yeah so he was still home and
dinners like it was yourself but you're
such a variable in the world of TV
dinners okay like of course compared to
a restaurant yeah it's not it's not that
great but if you compare to Sara Lee if
you compare to Mary calendars Marie
Callender's if you compare to what's
that will has a penguin Swanson's
Swanson Squared's for kids yeah by I
still like that
yes of Nicolina smick Elena's in the
States or is that
the Canadian thing I'm letting it okay
now never mind so find it
I'm foreign-born is how ketchup chips
and [ __ ] which are delicious but if you
compare all of them who wins hungry man
I remain hungry man wins because of
quantity though yeah because I like
Marie Callender's chicken potpie dresses
palm that's a different world that [ __ ]
burns my tongue in the top of my mouth
like nothing put that in a different
section just like pizza yeah she knows
dude yeah or DiGiorno that's a different
world that's a different world
the journos gourmet is health these
sponsors DiGiorno you don't have to I
don't know we don't that we don't have
to include this but have you guys have
you guys ever shoplifted before in your
life
I've told many stories of a bad thing I
don't think you understand how much of
their bags we all are not proud of it
we're not I've done it
yeah we're not part of it we regret it
but when you're a kid yeah some time
here a kid just like the things that I
could like put in my pocket like little
thick just to say that I did it
trinkets I still have come caught
cumquat once oh because it was like it
was like the most expensive thing in a
grocery store
I would like find it was like dark
chocolate is usually or razor blades
razor blades
[Laughter]
kumquats are like like I don't like
$7.99 each for this little tiny thing
they're so tropical oh maybe in Canada
there's so many trees are free mind you
that was like 12 years ago but yeah and
and and and saffron you're the spice oh
yeah it still [ __ ] expensive that
phonics you saw those things no need for
these you look at a grocery store were
you opening a restaurant or what bro
vices is [ __ ] a very Spanish restaurant
you're like you're gonna open up a tent
at a bazaar in Aladdin in Agrabah he's
feeling farmers market items and [ __ ] I
think I get over you correctly about
what's the most expensive saffron do you
guys ever go to Target and you're making
five mach-5 how much that schmuck is
expensive they're like $40 or in a case
yes that's Walmart they're in a case you
know they don't shave any better than
the mock threes
I had a mock five and it's the same
thing the two extra plays on Tony dude I
got like 60 hairs on my face they all I
have the same range but I've been use it
for six years dude that's just still
sharp as [ __ ] oh look at my face I have
no you don't even like you do the drives
like you don't even need to put anything
you're just like I think no I literally
do this shaving cream is [ __ ] I just
like the water hit my face and I go yeah
it's done and I get every [ __ ] hair
possible why don't you just go get it
lasered off you're never gonna grow it
out in hopes of one day one day mad one
day I would look like that like this
yeah yeah I keep waiting for it I still
have the same Nevaeh is it Nivea or
Namibia you have the same whitening
Bayer
Nevaeh Nevaeh straight incoming bottle
at my house in Sacramento that my mom
got me for college to another 18 Wow I'm
not sure if it still works by still have
it Riley I never use it the first like
three or four years I was in college
because I didn't grow any favor damn I
just started getting disliked brother
jefe sure he does oh oh he does huh it's
like you know it's very similar to yours
yeah yeah that's interesting is I don't
even really use shaving cream just like
a little bit of soap sometimes like when
you in the shower
put a little soap on there oh come on
you say it sounds sexy can't the deeper
and then when I say to somebody
[Applause]
[Music]